my goals for 2018 oh the classics many  Terry Bay you know the race I love them  go that hard and that deep and have a  cobbles and then roads kind of get you  kind of feel like you do in the last  week of Earth ground so really it's this  year will be quite different forward  three and he's really going down the Jim  rubes been a bit more focused in  November and December and cultivated a  lot of gym training try and create a bit  more strength and speed on the bike  ian is using the science pork products  in these trading and making sure that if  he is getting the right proteins and the  right carbs at the right time of the day  and it's really important to get the  timing of the day right you know a lot  of protein before and after and the  overnight protein and stuff was never  really used before faster finish  [Music]